hola buenas tardes los ministros de
interior se han reunido aquí en bruselas
para aprobar esta directiva de
protección temporal es la primera vez
que se utiliza a pesar de que existe
desde hace 20 años se utilice creo
justamente para acoger a todos los
refugiados provenientes de la guerra de
los balcanes pero nunca ya se llegó a
aplicar ahora los países han decidido
utilizarla para dar cobijo a todos los
refugiados ucranianos todas las personas
que vengan de ucrania y llegan a
territorio europeo se les va a acoger
también a las personas que sean
refugiadas o apátridas que se
encontraban en ucrania y que huyen de la
guerra y que llegan a territorio europeo
también se las va a acoger a los
nacionales de terceros países como
marroquíes o venecianos por ejemplo se
les podrá repatriar o sus países de
origen si así lo desean con esta nueva
directiva los ucranianos recibirán un
estatus automático muy muy parecido así
como si se les ofreciera asilo tendrán
acceso así a vivienda a seguridad social
también permisos de trabajo o de
estudios en cualquier país europeo se
tendrá en cuenta también sus raíces
familiares y tiene amigos o familiares
en países europeos recordemos que casi
un millón de personas ya han cruzado a
la unión europea se expidan que lleguen
millones más asegurado bruselas por eso
se ha intentado actuar con la máxima
celeridad se apostó por esta nueva
medida el pasado domingo y puede entrar
en las próximas horas en vigor los
países tienen ahora que acelerar todo el
trabajo técnico para poderse aplicar en
principio esta medida tendrá una
duración de un máximo de tres años un
año luego prorrogable hasta un máximo de
tres años aunque ha habido mucha
polémica porque esta medida no se tomó
por ejemplo con la con los refugiados
provenientes ante la guerra de siria
hace cinco años